>> Alright, so that was helpful with the HTML. Can you do
something similar and tell me how you think about reading a CSS file?
>> Alright, sure. Let's go look at it. Alright, so we've
got the CSS file. So CSS stands for cascading style sheets.
>> Okay. The cascading part is, sort of, you can define things in multiple
different ways, and it will always be the last definition that, that gets used.
>> Okay. What's going on, like, with these sorts
of things? Yeah, so, so we've got HTML and body.
So, all of these rules will be applied to any element
that starts with HTML or body. And then this rule will
apply just to the ones with body, and you'll notice it's
one of the same attributes between the two of them so.
>> So, this margin is going to supersede that one?
>> Yeah. Yeah, it'll over ride it.
>> Okay, cool. Okay, so and this could say
Div for example? This could be just any HTML thing.
>> Yeah. So, you could define
styles for all Divs. That would be kind of weird
because there are so many Divs that it would just
be kind of, kind of strange. But, so here we've
got inputs. Those are like boxes that you type stuff in.
>> Now this is different. This is green.
>> Yeah. So, so this guy is talking about a class.
>> Okay. So, these other ones, where they don't have dots
in front of them, those are the main, the element themselves.
>> Mm-hm. So the thing right after the open
angle bracket.
>> Mm-hm.
>> When its got a dot, it's talking about the, the part
that says class equals. So, this one is referring to this particular class.
>> Heading class, okay.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Cool.
>> And then, here, we've got an element dot class name,
so it's only that kind of element's class names. So if.
>> Okay.
>> If we'd had a Div with a, with
a class title, this rule wouldn't be applied to it.
>> Okay
>> It's only going to be applied to heading once.
>> So, what about these? So, what's going on with
these like, at dash webkit dash keyframes? What is this?
>> This looks like it's probably some kind
of animation or like, maybe a hover over, something.
>> Okay. What do webkit and moz, what do those things mean?
>> Yeah, so this is, this is clearly referring to different kinds of browsers.
So it's probably like different ways of
doing things based on which browser you're in.
>> Oh, so is this, so when our front end engineers are all complaining
about, you know, lack of browser specification,
they're complaining about having to write these things?
>> Yeah, or, or probably more like this sort of
thing. Okay. I can, I can see why that'd be annoying.
>> Yeah.
>> Alright. It gets super annoying.
>> And is that about it? I mean,
there's elements. We've got classes. We've got this
blue stuff, which is just the rules you're
applying, the font size, the height. Is that about
all that's going on?
>> Yeah, pretty much. I mean you, you can do more complicated stuff in
CSS, but it's sort of preferable not to. [LAUGH] You mostly want the CSS file
to be as simple as possible. And just, sort of, give the basic positioning and
like coloring and all of that, and
then have the JavaScript deal with everything else.
>> Okay. Alright. well, I'm going to actually
try and do that thing that you said I shouldn't do. I going to try and change
the, some of the styling of all the
Divs and see if that does anything interesting.
>> Alright.
>> Okay.